happy fourth of July everyone merry and
i'm here with Jake hello happy fourth to
a happy 4th to you as well what a
fantastic time we live in what a
beautiful country and today we're going
to celebrate that by blowing up a small
piece of it with fireworks simulator
fireworks simulator this came out
actually last year but who cares we're
going to give it a whirl now because
what better day then that the fourth of
July America America let's get into it
this is the fantastic menu screen when
you hit a start game oh this is even
better looking cologne or Olympic Park
well go with Cologne I like Cologne I
don't know a problem with that give him
a sec fantastic all right and it comes
with some standard songs which song do
you like better it's due kamu rock okay
I'm gonna take your word for it I know
nothing about this and this is where it
kind of starts you out here with this is
a bow right so this is a boat and we're
loading it with explosives okay those
look like tacos um taco explosives and
then there's a color box Brock and go
comment now a lot of people don't know
this this game was apparently made with
real pyrotechnicians guiding them on I
don't know probably the specs of how far
away you're allowed to keep all the I
don't know the explosions all the
explosives away from the people call and
say I don't know I don't know that much
about fire um we need a pyrotechnician
for this i wish i had a pyrotechnician
to help me so they do have like options
up here there's um there's like
sequencer there's help as well I don't
know how much you get even needed that
but it looks like in terms of the way a
real fireworks simulation would go they
give you a lot of different options from
you know ground various heights of the
types of fireworks you want to use
and the space of how how like distance
you want them to be and then if you go
to the sequencers we can just kind of
give it a little check out so here is
this is what the timing of if you want
the fireworks to go to the beat pretty
much yeah so you've got like the
waveform up here and then you can like
place I guess time out the fireworks
that you've placed on your boat and make
like cool stuff with it oh so this
reminds me of lysing of Adobe Premiere
it does remind me like any video editing
software and what really seals the deal
with it is doesn't it also let you pick
the camera angles that you want when
you're showing it so as if this was a
broadcast of fireworks on TV we could
change the camera angle for all the all
the most perfect angles different angles
six different angles well so they boast
I was checking out their site so they
are you can pick this bad boy up on
steam it also claims that it's got over
100 authentic effects 30 launch racks I
don't know what a launch rack is I
assume it's one of the boats I don't
know I don't think it matters those
fireworks because they're all these
really cool extra effects that they've
added and no one gives a [ __ ] because
they just want to watch stuff explode
this was made by developer reality twist
who might sound familiar as they made
merry time search and rescue familiar it
is a rescue simulation game and then it
was published by rondo media and they've
made all sorts of simulation games these
people are like known for making
simulation style games they made rescue
simulators garbage truck simulator
roadside assistance airport they even
made a logistics company simulator just
in case you didn't get enough of
calculating at work you can come home
and start your own simular love you
start your own logistics company and and
simulate what it would feel like to hate
yourself
let's give this a whirl I want to see
what you've made so far so I just threw
random yeah show me what you did oh yeah
I guess we're just gonna find out what
it looks like you hit ignite are we
ready yeah I've got born ready your
seatbelts I'm so excited oh yeah
beautiful
no real mark yes hard to really I feel
like I'm in Cologne took it one step
further this makes me want a pretzel
real bad leave those angel look it's the
height I love will you change all right
off the water this is stunning with
firemen why we don't let you review yes
obviously it is what it is I think for
its simulation style games it's really
shine I couldn't ask for anything more
oh I got any sparklings on the bottom oh
yeah I like the ones that look like a
willow tree like flickers all the way
down there's a rainbow one yeah the
thing is is that I don't know if any of
the fireworks are calling out of there
for me so I just kind of like throw
random stuff down I think that's what
pyrotechnician is due to though like I
think we give them too much credit well
if you think that they've really
considered all the options of different
diameter of circle fireworks I think
you're lying yourself I think they just
throw down colors and call it a day yeah
just kind of like set things up and in
smoke while they oh there was you gotta
score wait let me see this effect
variation nice beat synchronization note
you didn't synchronize the BD yes not um
I don't think we should save that no I
think we can do better let's try again
we have fourth of July loaded but
doesn't have much to it we still need to
kind of fine tune this bad boy so go
ahead and load that up I love him he
tells me that give me a sec you needn't
finish second because he's a busy guy
yeah he's developing a lot of simulation
games now we're in a different location
where we know there's no books we I know
I'm Olympic Olympia park okay it was a
interesting thing about this go on there
are two locations to firing sites in
this one so we've got this part here
okay safe and then whatever this is an
isolated a doc made of
concrete concrete and stone it's a
pillars some weak-ass pillars all right
put some tacos in there we're gonna make
this nuts I'm just gonna go crazy I want
you to go crazy Oh goons and Brazilian
comments and I still be hidden come I
like the sound of that one slow falling
star that sounds beautiful so on this
one this is the one where we gonna put
all the ground level fireworks and then
we're gonna put our higher up once I
don't know why you put them there
instead but if you like you know a lot
about this do you feel like as you've
made this a good point simulation I
you've learned a lot yeah is my next job
I think this is probably how it all
begins to though honestly like you get
excited or inspired about fire you learn
about fire and then you find a way to
make your fire obsession a reality to
share with the people and only every
once in a while have a horrible
egregious error that results in the
burning of civilians good story when I
was really young old enough to know
better but young enough to be a little
brat there was candles on my dining
table and I was like what's this so I
like totally messed with the fire and
touched it and then before I knew what
had happened I had burned my parents
really good tablecloth and I was afraid
that they would find out think I was
insane so I covered it with I like
crumpled the table like the dog had did
it and then when my dad got home and was
like what's going on I was like I think
the dog got on the table um but I saved
it don't worry about it and my dad was
like I'm not a very good liar my dad was
just like oh ok thanks for saving the
day and then later on he was like Mary
what's up with that the tablecloth had
wax all over it and there were
fingerprints in the wax and I was and
then I cried and so for like a few years
after that my dad thought I was gonna be
a big pyro he thought I was like
obsessed with fire because I touched it
I think that's natural of every child's
life that you just
a touch fire look at it I mean like I
remember camping as a kid you know
you're always just I spent hours just
standing I still did just staring into
the fire you know that's his dad takes
does not normally I heard about not know
I I thought this was thing that we did I
want to see some of those hot camera
angle action oh you show me some more
camera angles yeah well put some show me
what you're doing I feel like I know you
have thought into this don't ask don't
act like you didn't put thought into it
so you're this is a long song this is
like a 3-minute song yeah we want to
change you want to change camera angles
like every what two seconds to you want
to every two seconds we can get away
with this is gonna be a disaster I'm
gonna set cologne blew fire
pyrotechnician here oh wait it's you
yeah so you're going from premium rangel
323 like that is a good system whew
there we go it's beautiful um so there's
gonna be a [ __ ] I feel really
good about it what do you think wait no
I want to think about this are you ready
to play this ah mmm are we ready to play
this I feel pretty good about this all
right let's hit play but don't hit
ignite first all right I was just taking
the scene I think we should take in the
beautiful scene it looks really nice and
I think we should watch it together as a
people for the fourth of July this is
safe too all right can I hit ignite
let's hit ignite and let's start the
music please maestro big nice all right
let's look at it
Oh
Oh
ah
Oh
tell me
green screams really yeah well thank you
guys for joining us on this amazing
fourth of July spectacular we hope
you've enjoyed it as much as we have
I've enjoyed it we've have a second
career now and I hope you guys have an
awesome fourth of July and enjoy
yourselves and remember america [ __ ]
yeah
be